Speaker 1: It's happening. A supporter of
domestic terrorists is now on the Homeland
Security Committee. Marjorie Taylor GREENE, the
radical Republican congresswoman, a joke of a
woman making the United States a global laughing
stock who defended and supported the domestic
terrorists who stormed the Capitol on January
6th of 2021, who pushed 911 conspiracy theories,
who talked about Jewish space lasers. She will
sit on the Homeland Security Committee, the woman
that said they would have been armed and would
have won if she led the January 6th coup is now
on the Homeland Security Committee. The Homeland
Security Committee should be investigating people
like Marjorie Taylor. GREENE But it is Marjorie
Taylor GREENE who in this backwards United States
ends up on that very committee. Who does she think
are the threats? People like Hunter Biden, people
who she claims are socialists and communists, even
though they are not. You know the drill. Rolling
Stone reporting. The new GOP controlled House is
letting liars and conspiracy theorists lead its
agenda. That is exactly right. Kevin McCarthy, the
new speaker of the House, indicated he will allow
Congressman Jorge Santos currently facing multiple
investigations for lying to voters about his
identity to also have a committee position. We're
going to get to that later on in the program.
Rolling Stone reminds us GREENE was removed from
the House Education and Labor Committee and the
Budget Committee in February of 21 over backlash
from statements she made before her election,
including that a bullet to the head was the
quickest way to remove Nancy Pelosi from her then
speakership. GREENE was also revealed to harbor
a belief in Q and on having spread conspiracy
theories about mass shootings and suggested
911 was a hoax. GREENE will now serve on the
Homeland Security Committee. I think it's great,
Kevin McCarthy reportedly said on Tuesday some of
Greene's priorities. She recently said to Tucker
Carlson she believes that current Department of
Homeland Security Secretary Michael Caucus should
be impeached. Paul Gosar is also on the Committee
for Natural Resources. He was censured by the
House and ousted after he tweeted that animal
battle sequence where Alexandria Ocasio-Cortez
was killed. Kevin McCarthy sure had to cut some
pretty damn wild deals to get those votes and
become Speaker of the House. That is abundantly
clear. This is the United States of America in
2023. You support a failed coup. You defend the
rioters. You say if you had been in charge of the
coup, you would have won the coup. You get to stay
in Congress, by the way, and then you get a job
on the committee in charge of homeland security.
This is where we are. And what of her experience
even ostensibly qualifies for her for this role?
Is it the harassment she engaged in of the victims
of school shootings? Does that qualifier to be on
the Homeland Security Committee? Is it any of the
long list of things we've talked about before?
It is embarrassing that this is where the country
is. And you know how it'll go. Two years from now,
we'll look back and will say, what are Marjorie
Taylor Green's accomplishments on this committee?
And there will be none, nothing positive anyway.
And then they will say, well, we couldn't get
anything done because of Democrats in the Senate
or whatever, but definitely vote for me again,
because now I'm part of the in-group. And
that's really what this is about for Marjorie
Taylor. GREENE And also, that's a lot of of the
catalyst for this new war she's engaged in with
fellow lunatic Congresswoman Lauren Boebert.
And that's what I want to talk about next.